avatar 2 hasn't come out yet
it's been in production because they've
already started production on this movie
for 13 years it's supposed to come out
in 2022 remember avatar when it came out
and everyone's like oh it's so by the
way avatar
sucked all right avatar
sucked
um the film was announced in 2010 after
the release of avatar
with writing and visual effects prep
work happening simultaneously for seven
years
filming began in 2017 and it's expected
to conclude
in 2022 it was one of the films affected
by covet 19 yeah but no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
excuse me if avatar started phil
started pre-production and if filming
began in 2017
don't give me this [ __ ] covet 19
being affected because
covert 19 wasn't a [ __ ] issue in 2017
so don't don't don't [ __ ] don't give
me that [ __ ]
do you think anybody's gonna give a [ __ ]
about this movie when it comes out
because i [ __ ] doubt it i doubt it
yeah and they're gonna make six of them
exactly
i have no idea why they're still [ __ ]
making these movies
no clue
very odd
i don't understand the movie i don't
think it's normal
very rarely is a movie good enough that
you could wait
13 years for a sequel avatar 2
avatar the only reason avatar was even
any people liked it
wasn't because the plot was great
because the plot was we already know
[ __ ]
pocahontas you know or fern gully
the only reason avatar people liked it
was because visually it was a very
pretty movie you'd seen an imax 3d
and all that stuff it was pretty i get
it it's avatar was like a theme park
ride
basically and now i ironically it is
also a theme park ride
but dude you [ __ ] serious right now
like the movie to wait james cameron has
made some great films i am not
going to pretend that james cameron
isn't the [ __ ] he's doing aliens and
stuff like that
[ __ ] great right terminator 2 [ __ ]
great
titanic not my cup of tea but you can't
deny that it was a great film
what the [ __ ] was he thinking that
avatar was
like that's what happens some people get
too much success like [ __ ] james
cameron
and then they just make this weird
weird [ __ ] you know
true lies was good too but just because
he made other great movies i mean
so what
avatar two so check this out so so this
is this is
development in 2006 cameron stated that
if avatar was successful he hoped to
make two sequels of the film in 2010
he said the film's widespread success
confirmed that he would
the sequels were originally scheduled to
be released
in december 2014 to 2015 and now we're
talking six years ago
include certain scenes in the first film
he included certain scenes in the first
film for future
story follow-ups cameron plan to shoot
the sequels back to back and begin
working once the novel
is nailed down he stated that the
sequels would widen the universe while
exploring other moons of uh pandora
the first sequel would focus on the
oceans of pandora
and also feature more of a rainforest he
intended to capture footage for the
sequel
at the bottom of the mariana trench
using deep water
submersibles okay this is the [ __ ]
problem
with this is the [ __ ]
problem with james cameron james cameron
from movie guy to being a [ __ ]
explorer he's always doing submarine
[ __ ]
and all this fun [ __ ] stuff like he
went you know to explore the titanic
wreckage and all that stuff
you're making a movie about blue aliens
that throw spears at [ __ ]
space marines nobody that's watching
that film
is gonna go oh wow he filmed the movie
at the mariana trench it's not a
documentary
at this point i think james cameron uses
the money to go on a little personal
adventures
why would you need to film the bottom of
the mariana trench
to make the movie good
honestly it [ __ ] explain that to me
why in the [ __ ] world
would you need to do that exactly it's
not a documentary so what's the point
in 2011 cameron stated that he was
starting to design the ocean ecosystem
of pandora
and that the other worlds would be
included in the story the storyline
although continuing the environmental
theme
of the first film would not be str uh
strident uh
since the film will concentrate on
entertainment
the sequels were confirmed as continuing
to follow the characters of jake
and nitiri in december 2009 cameron
implied that the humans would return as
antagonists of the story in 2011 cameron
stated his intention to film his sequels
at a higher frame rate
than the industry standard of 24 frames
per second in order to add heightened
sense of reality
in 2013 cameron announced that the
sequels would be filmed in new zealand
with performance capture to take place
2014 an agreement with new zealand
government required at least
one world premiere to be held in
wellington
and at least 500 million
uh to be spent on production activity in
new zealand including live-action
filming and visual effects
the new zealand government announced it
would raise its baseline tax rebate for
filmmakers from 15
to 20 with 25
uh to international productions in some
cases 40
for new zealand productions as to find
okay so they're doing what the
springfield did when all the [ __ ]
actors went to film did they just raise
their prices that's pretty funny
actually
in april 2016 uh james cameron announced
at cinecon
that cinemacon that there will be four
avatar sequels
all of which will be filmed
simultaneously with release dates of
december
2018 2020 2022 2023 and late october
2016 it's reported that cameron was
going to push the glass-free 3d with the
sequels
but he later disagreed with these rumors
and did not think the technology would
be there yet in march 2017 cameron
revealed that avatar 2
would not be released in 2018 as
originally believed on april 27 2017 the
releases so whatever
my point is none of them have come out
none of them come out and
the funny part to me the funny part to
me
about all of this
that i that i find
[ __ ] hilarious is that
the only reason avatar
was as successful as it was
was because of the movie because of the
theater industry because of 3d
movies and imacs watching avatar on your
tv at home
it doesn't [ __ ] it's it's it's one of
those there's certain movies that are
made specifically for imax or that are
made specifically for 3d
watching them at home it's not the same
it's [ __ ] stupid
there's no point at this point james
cameron has taken so long to make this
movie
that the theater industry is effectively
dead
it's effectively dead good [ __ ] luck
go
put that movie out in a theater and see
if people show up i doubt it
i really really doubt it you waited too
long
because you wanted to go on your [ __ ]
submarine adventures
and now you don't get to [ __ ] make a
movie that people are gonna see
go release it on hbo max like everybody
else
just [ __ ] ridiculous
waited too long big guy you waited way
too long